winter is coming so why not warm
yourself by the fire book of the
stranger Game of Thrones season 6
episode four reminder I don't do spoiler
free anymore so here we go without
having to resort to big action
set-pieces this episode just feels like
a lot goes on it's a lot of stuff I like
everything is moving and it's not just
sort of nudging it's not indicating it's
not going maybe we'll go here later in
the season it's moving so where to start
well we actually start with John not
quite having left yet which I was kind
of annoyed I'm like he had that great
line at the end of the last episode you
know my watch has ended am i cool badass
line I guess he's gonna go off and do
his own things and we opened and he's
still there and his friends trying to
talk him into not leaving yet i'm like
this seems like an odd stall what's
going on here and then Sansa shows up
there and I I gotta be honest that just
felt good for all the near misses how
many times starts you know almost got
reunited or almost you know got there in
the nick of time I I had assumed I
hadn't even I know they gave you really
thought about I just assumed that he was
gonna be gone by the time since I got
there cuz that's the sort of thing that
always happens to them so for her to get
there and for them to embrace him to
have have a really touching moment and
for Sansa to have a high degree of
self-awareness but ya know I was awful
please just tell me you forgive me and
it was nice and it was sweet and it
still felt true to the characters and it
was just a good moment it's a good
reason to keep him there and I like a
lot of the other interactions that went
on there obviously mellow sandra's
really kind of still struggling with the
face because she's like well John's the
prince that was promised in Davos
immediately goes well you said that
about Stannis so you kind of see without
dwelling on her you see with Melisandre
this is really kind of struggling with
her faith right now because something
miraculous has happened but she isn't so
sure of herself and doesn't know what to
make of it anymore I really like to be
fairly brief just sort of I don't want
to call it a stand-up at the moment that
happened between Brienne and Davos where
brie amazing steps and it goes yeah I
killed your kid
and that was such an odd moment cuz
normally something like that happens
it's a character you really like you
know putting down a character you don't
like but I like both characters and was
like oh ouch we see Robin Arryn for the
first time in a long time and it's weird
seeing that King kind of grown up I mean
it was always a little weird looking but
I don't know and of course little finger
doing what he always does and playing
the situation it's not quite as
satisfying in this instance because he
doesn't have to be as clever about it
when he's dealing with Robert E he's a
bit more blatant which is a shame
because it looks hit it makes him look
less clever than I know he actually is
just cuz he doesn't need to try as hard
to manipulate this kid over amrein
Tyrion doing a very careful balancing
act with this whole thing you know
trying to negotiate and do the sorts of
things that add someone who understands
politics he knows is the best way to
move forward but at the same time the
people right behind him who are
theoretically on his side just they
don't want to go they would probably
hate his much more than the people that
he's negotiating with getting to give up
their way of life so watching him walk
that line and do it pretty well but at
the same time you're like tyrion i'm not
sure you're on as solid footing as you
think you are but he's still managing so
far and I'm enjoying watching it some
more great stuff with the high Sparrow I
just I jonathan pryce was so good in
this role I will never get tired of
seeing him and watching him and just
listening to him and Marjorie you know
see me like she's starting to crack but
then having a really strong moment with
her brother and then almost immediately
after that we could see the lady Elaina
again and she's ready to really lay down
the law and put it all on the line to
get Marjorie back and you know honestly
this episode this a lot of just women
having had enough we kind of tip making
their stands putting their foot down its
I don't know if it was an intentional
running theme in this episode but it's
in here a lot and I enjoyed it although
unfortunately not all the female
characters get to have good little
victory moments because we lost OSHA to
Ramsey damn I hate this guy I mean I it
really does seem like Ramsey is
specifically designed to make you hate
him more than Joffrey cuz again I mean I
hated job for everybody hated Joffrey
but Java
was just this prick you like people are
gonna take him out he can't defend
himself he's just there because he's
gang and for as long as people put up
with him he'll stay there but you knew
he was on borrowed time I mean ruling
the way he was was gone into a rebellion
Ramsey is ruthless and scary that was
the thing about Joffrey he couldn't fend
for himself Ramsey can and that makes
him scary which makes it less likely
that people are going to stand up to him
and I am sure that he will die at some
point they're gonna make us wait for it
though you thought it was a long time
waiting for Joffrey to die it's got to
feel like an eternity before they kill
this guy but then of course the big
moment you know I've been really
skeptical of all the stuff going on with
dr. with the Dothraki and with De Niro
some like Oh what is this going anywhere
we're just stalling and maybe that was
still the case but you know what I
really like this closer and yes it's a
very deliberate blatant call back to
what happened at the end of the first
season so should I be giving it so much
credit that's basically just rehashing
something that it did five years ago
part of me wants to give the show crap
from that is like oh you finally brought
her up to that point that you had a rat
forever ago can we finally move forward
from that now but I can't really give
the show crappy though kind of 12
because I enjoyed it too much huge grin
on my face was yeah so yes and now I
finally I really want the show that
she's got an army of Dothraki you know
what I don't really care what she goes
if she wants to go back to marine and
get a dragger or if she just wants to
hop on some boats and go to Westeros
right now don't care roll over whoever's
in your way please that's pretty much it
honestly no genuine complaints I mean
some things happen that he didn't like
like oh she gettin killed but I'm not
gonna say that that makes the episode
bat it's a it's a plot turn that am I oh
but it's not bad storytelling it's
perfectly effective of storytelling is
consistent with the characters it
affected me because I cared about those
characters oh the other thing I forgot
to mention was Theon and Yara and their
reunion and I was expecting that to be
clunky as heck but
no that work that was really good this
is just a really good solid episode I
mean it's really getting the ball
rolling things moving it ends on a great
note i've got no actual legitimate
complaints so four episodes it i'm
declaring this one the highlight of the
season so far let's see where they can
take it from here so that's my thoughts
i'm assuming you have already seen book
of the stranger so what did you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it do not forget to like
subscribe check me out on twitter at
council of geeks check out the council
of geeks podcasts on iTunes and stitcher
links below and until next time this
council is adjourned